[Musique]
il est demandé maintenant un
intellectuel ce qu'ils pensent de vous
je veux dire à votre ami pierre bergé
puis à berger vous avez écrit andrew lee
vont nous présenter l'homme et l'artiste
et je voudrais me poser de questions qui
est bernard buffet questions
embarrassantes
ah oui mon cher paris n'ose une question
très très embarrassante parce que perdre
un buffet qui est le peintre sur lequel
on parle le plus ne pas le français
puisque puisqu'elle souhaite espagnol le
prince français sur lequel on parle plus
c'est sûrement celui qui parle le moins
et cette espèce de gloire qui lui arrive
en ce moment l'accumulation de loi j'en
aurais très peur si ça arrive à un autre
cas lui mais comme il vous l'a dit tout
à l'heure ça ne me touche pas je crois
que même sa peinture une fois qu'il l'a
fait ne me touche plus non plus qu'une
chose terminer c'est un être extrêmement
modeste extrêmement réservés et surtout
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille beaucoup
il n'est pas insensible à non pas du
tout n'est pas un centime n'est pas
sensible aux mêmes choses aux choses
auxquelles nous sommes ordinairement
sensible il dit des choses par exemple
tu avais une rate contredire tu as dit
qu'une lisez pas c'est pas vrai tu lis
beaucoup et tulle et surtout des remous
dans fond tu n'aimes pas la littérature
habituel parce qu'elle ne t'apporte rien
et parce que l'art que tu fais te suffit
à toi-même est une chose trop importante
pour que tu puisse la comparer que tu
puisse le comparer à l'art des autres et
il n'a lui nick hamm unis sartre ni
kafka parce que quand il a tellement
travaillé et il a bien fait de dire ça
et parinaud la question vous lui avez
posées me semble particulièrement juste
quand il a tellement travaillé dix
heures de suite dans son atelier comme
il le fait presque chaque jour il n'a
pas envie le soir de travailler à
nouveau en lisant des écrivains bourton
en écoutant de la musique pourtant les
envies de se distraire et de se divertir
il écoute beaucoup de musique
ils écoutent de la musique facile parce
que ça m'amuse
et également il dit qu'il est triste on
dit qu'il est triste ce pas vrai du tout
une pas triste du tout il est au
contraire très drôle et donne les genoux
surtout les mauvais est-ce qu'il prend
un exercice physique par exemple
ah non parce qu'à cette heure-là il
n'est pas des exercices physiques de la
radio c'est cela vous devrez me dire non
mais je le vis pas comme faut s'attarder
sur un cheval ah oui mais comme il dit
lui même c'est pas à cheval c'est un
fauteuil de paralytique parce que il a
trouvé un cheval camaro gueule je fais
le king cole voilà c'est vrai qu'il peut
pas compter et là il a voulu un cheval
tu vas courir alors il est sur le bon
cheval comme ça mais rarement parce que
là non plus rarement le temps car il
travaille beaucoup c'est sûr tout cela
est presque répondu et pierre bergé à la
seconde question je voulais vous poser
et qui est dans quelle mesure sa
peinture intéresse-t-elle bernard buffet
et bien je crois qu'elle le trouble bon
coup car ils n'arrêtent jamais très
franc que même quand il est tout repos
même quand il n'y pense pas même quand
ils n'en parlent pas d'ailleurs ils
n'ont pas jamais il n'arrête pas de
travailler
c'est un problème toujours nouveau la
toile blanche et lui le phénomène de la
création est un problème très important
car il ne croit absolument pas
l'inspiration
il sait très bien que ce sont des images
de ce fait est que cette fameuse
inspiration ce n'est jamais que des
heures accumulées les unes aux autres
est passé dans l'atelier sait très bien
que l'on n'a pas l'inspiration en une
seconde est que le tableau se fait comme
ça pourquoi font-ils parce qu'il a
beaucoup de choses à dire et il pas
beaucoup bourse là on lui a reproché sa
grande production
on lui a reproché et certains
journalistes amis ont même voulu roule à
cacher ou la diminuer ils ont absolument
lutter et j bernard buffet essayé de
cacher son autre grande production ils
auraient tout à fait tort il pas
beaucoup parce qu'il a beaucoup à dire
car à la peintre qui ne produirait qu'un
seul tableau pas rond s'il n'avait rien
à dire ils feraient mieux de ne rien
perdre lui pourrait pas un tableau par
jour
sylla chaque jour quelque chose de
nouveau à dire il peut pas long
[Musique]